this is the story of how one of the
wealthiest families in America lost
their entire Fortune when the head of
this family was 16 his mom gave him a
hundred dollars and he turned that 100
into over 200 billion dollars in today's
money with ferries and railroads that's
roughly 50 of the U.S treasury at the
time the problem was he didn't trust his
family with his business or money he had
13 kids but when he died he left his
entire Fortune to just one of his sons
the rest of his kids got practically
nothing and at first it worked his son
ended up doubling the family fortune the
rest of the family however only knew how
to spend money Mansions lavish parties
Yachts you name it they bought it so
within just 50 years of the patriarch's
death that entire 200 billion dollar
Fortune had completely vanished but
before we reveal who this family was
this video was made with the help of
motion array the insane platform that
gives you everything you need to create
stunning videos with unlimited stock
videos photos Motion Graphics music
sound effects and more click the link in
the pin comment to start free now and
this family is the Vanderbilts and